I've mentioned a few times before that
if you ever shop on amazon.com you can
support our work by first going to david
pakman.com slash amazon a but a few
humane my straps louis were purchased
over the last week by one of our viewers
through that amazon link of course at
the end of the day we get a list of
items people have purchased but no
personally identifying information
whatsoever I've heard of these humane
mouse traps I've also heard they just do
not work I mean I guess the idea is I've
dealt with mice at my old place in
western Massachusetts the idea of this
trap is the mouse goes in and adore sort
of closes on it the mouse is unharmed
and then you take the mouse away and
from what I've been told the mouse sort
of finds itself better finds its way
back to your place and if not that Mouse
that other mice do uh I don't know but
from my experience the humane mouse
traps as humane as they are are not
particularly effective well uh effective
in that they do capture the mouse and
they can take it outside and let it go
it is a trap in the sense that it traps
the mouse yes so the traps themselves do
work yet to trap the mouse but what some
people will do is drive a few miles away
and let the maps out yeah I've heard
even that's not enough I don't know I'm
no expert in mice yeah me neither but
anyway people buy them the most
effective thing I had done was uh I
don't love it but I you know what what
do I know I don't know um I had the bait
set for the mice so the mice eat like
this neon green stuff and then
supposedly they don't die in your
apartment you know they go somewhere
else and then they die but it can happen
that they'll build I like in your walls
and then a smell will develop
fortunately that has that happened to me
so far and then when I moved to New York
City from western mass and left my place
there was a guy who's who is an expert
in this he said listen I don't think
you've got an infestation here I think
you're dealing with one specific mouse
family the best thing is I'm going to
get some uh old tennis ball containers
the tubes uh and imma put some peanut
butter inside and I'm also going to put
just a good old-fashioned regular mouse
trap the old will you know the cartoon
ones that you see in cartoons which do
snap the mouse's neck and uh then that's
probably going to deal with the problem
and I said you know what have at it
here's a key I'm leaving to New York
next week let's deal with this while I'm
gone and and from his report to it was
very effective and I did not have a
mouse problem again knock on wood uh but
yeah I mean you know I don't feel great
that I'm snapping my sis neck in my
apartment obviously Louis but at a
certain point you know the problem had
to be solved let's put it that way also
when you have those traditional traps
there might be a bit more of a clean up
if you know what I mean yeah there's
that yes uh fortunately no cleanup
necessary during that escapade humane
mouse traps I applaud you I mean by all
means uh god bless you for for
attempting it if it works that's great
david pakman.com slash amazon anything
you buy humane mouse traps whatever uh
supports the david pakman show if you
use that link